do you ever regret your behavior on
Twitter
there were a couple of times but very
rarely
can you describe the big strategy before
we dive back into the October Revolution
uh my strategy do you have a strategy or
is it does it come from the heart
or does it come from the brain
it comes from I want to have fun
so that's literally what it comes down
to it's like this is Girls Just Want to
Have Fun
are you drunk what is it what are you
what is in there
I'm very cheeky I'm I have the holiday
spirit even though it's not the holidays
oh that's eggnog Delirious I did not
sleep much last night I've been uh which
is I think the second time we talked or
the third time the second time I I
stayed up almost all night oh I know I
keep track of when you come and go yeah
so my door camera points in your garage
so I know when you're leaving or coming
home my camera points at your bedroom
from the inside but I shouldn't have
told you that now
let me ask you this because this
something's been bothering me yes there
was a chair that you threw out yep and
I'm broken and I was looking at my
camera and I'm like let me see when he
threw this out and then one time you
went to the garbage and you adjusted it
to make it stick out of the garbage even
more what were you doing there
uh was I oh
to make sure that people know there's a
chair in there is that really what you
did well like the garbage person so they
know it's the chair so they don't get
like I I always think I don't want them
to get like hurt or whatever oh okay
like they open the thing it's like uh
chair got it I don't know I don't know
what I was thinking okay it was really
odd I didn't know how to get rid of a
chair it was broken it was like crack